[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
the United States Public Health Service
as it exists today is the product of
experience extending over a period of
nearly a hundred and fifty years it was
originally created as the marine
hospital service for the purpose of
providing medical care to American
merchant seamen the marine hospital
service was established by an act of
Congress signed by the second President
of the United States John Adams on July
16 1790 8:00 this service was originally
supported by attacks on American
merchant seamen but this tax was later
abolished the tax was collected by the
collector of the customs of the Treasury
Department and the marine hospital
service came under the jurisdiction of
that department where it remains today
the first marine hospital located at
Norfolk Virginia was purchased from that
state in 81
the second was built in Boston
Massachusetts generals and some of the
medical personnel were utilized by both
the Union and the Confederacy for the
care of the scan wounded of the military
forces
it frequently happened that the medical
officers of the early marine hospitals
were the first physician to diagnose
such diseases as cholera fever and
smallpox which seriously endangered the
public health at ports of entry as time
went on the work of the service became
of such increasing importance to the
public health of the country that
Congress gradually extended its duties
until it became in function a federal
Health Service recognizing the value of
mobility and military discipline in an
organization which had to combat
epidemic diseases Congress authorized
the organization of the marine hospital
service along military lines with
officers holding Commission's in grades
similar to those of officers of the
medical departments of the Army and the
Navy in 1912 the name of the service was
changed to that borne by this
organization today the United States
Public Health Service the Public Health
Service is administered by the Surgeon
General who is responsible directly to
the secretary of the Treasury to
Congress and to the President of the
United States we will now hear the
Surgeon General briefly outlined the
work of the Public Health Service
although the first responsibility for
Public Health rests upon the states and
localities in our country the federal
government through the Public Health
Service there's much to prevent disease
and to improve the health of all the
people this is done in many ways one
very skilled group of men and women some
disease and means of preventing it other
service officers guard the ports to
prevent introduction of disease envoy
others have the duty of preventing
faulting the spread of infections within
our own territory under the provisions
of the recently enacted Social Security
Act the Public Health Service is
cooperating with every state and
territory in the development in those
states and territories of a national
health focus this cooperative work
between the federal state and local
governments should provide new standards
of Health ready for the people in
addition the manufacturer of all serums
and vaccines so
the country is carefully supervised by
the Public Health Service studies a
result concerning drug addiction and
Mental Hygiene it conducts marine
hospitals in which are treated American
sailors in addition their service keeps
in constant touch with health conditions
throughout the world the weekly reports
from every consular officer it
encourages health education in various
problems of disease prevention in rough
follows you will see in much more detail
the way is in which this organization
operates for human service for centuries
it has been well known that epidemic
diseases follow the lines of Commerce
and travel during colonial times and in
the early days of our republic the
introduction of yellow fever smallpox
cholera and other diseases from foreign
countries by ships one sign no means
uncommon epidemics of yellow fever from
this source occurred as late as 1798 in
New York in Baltimore as late as 1832
and in Philadelphia as late as 1853 many
outbreaks of smallpox and cholera we're
the result of cases brought in by
vessels the danger of introduction of
diseases from abroad has paralleled in
growth the remarkable development of
Transportation on the sea on the land
and in the air the transportation of
disease has been as much facilitated by
improved mechanical methods as has the
transportation of persons or property
maritime quarantine was at first
undertaken by the states and cities but
is now administered by the Public Health
Service at all the ports of the United
States and its possessions to perform
these functions the service has been
given quarantine jurisdiction over all
ships and all persons both citizens and
aliens coming into American ports from
abroad
in its quarantine work the United States
Public Health Service maintains a fleet
of trim and speedy boarding tugs
which carry the quarantine officers out
to the vessels arriving at United States
ports when a vessel arrives at
quarantine the medical quarantine
officer a nurse and an inspector go out
to it in one of these boarding tugs so
well known to seamen and ocean travelers
they draw alongside the vessel and gore
board the quarantine officer meets the
ship's doctor and the purser the purser
turns over to him a certain records of
the vessel voyage for inspection
especially the bill of health and the
health record enroute which shows all
cases of illness occurring on board
during the trip ah the list here shows a
suspicious case of illness in a member
of the crew let's see now what happens
the quarantine officer is taken to the
sick bay in the crew's quarters to
examine the patient his experience and
training in the detection of the
symptoms of rare as well as the common
diseases tells him that this patient is
suffering from typhus fever he orders
the patient to be removed from the
vessel
and foot aboard the quarantine tug to be
taken ashore all persons who have been
in contact with the patient and thus
have been exposed to the disease are
also ordered on board the tug the
patient and the contacts are taken to
the detention hospital in this instance
Hoffman Island in New York Harbor
on their arrival the sick patient is
taken directly to the hospital here he
has given appropriate treatment and
cared for until he has recovered every
facility is made available in such cases
both for the benefit of the patient
himself and for the protection of others
as this happens to be a case of
old-world typhus fever which is known to
be spread by the body louse the contacts
those who have had association with the
patient during the voyage are first
taken to the delousing plant here they
must remove all of their clothing freely
sprayed with soap and water next year
sent under the shower and finally he one
is sprayed with an insecticide that
kills any lice or nits that may still
remain in their hair the clothing of
these contact is placed in net bags and
these bags are sent to the fumigating
room this clothing together with the
baggage of the contact is placed in
fumigating chambers where it is
thoroughly disinfected if necessary the
contacts are isolated in the detention
hospital for observation every
precaution is taken by the quarantine
officers to prevent the introduction of
disease into the United States when the
quarantine work has been completed and
the ship declared free from danger the
medical officers of the Public Health
Service then turned to the inspection of
immigrants this scene shows the
well-known immigration station at Ellis
Island New York during the busy period
of a few years ago more prospective
citizens of this country arriving for a
rod entered through this world-renowned
station than through any other port of
the country in past years thousands of
aliens arrived at Ellis Island daily and
each one had to undergo an examination
at the hands of the medical officers of
the Public Health Service
in past times too many of them arrived
only to be turned back at our very gates
because of mental or physical defect
this was a necessary but somewhat cruel
procedure and caused many heartaches
untold hardships and much unnecessary
expense to avoid this condition a new
system was inaugurated by international
consent in 1925 since which year
intending immigrants have been examined
in foreign countries by public health
service officers who were assigned to
American consulates for this purpose the
prospective immigrant makes application
through the American Consul who if the
applicant comes within the quota
prescribed by Congress arranges for an
examination by the Public Health Service
medical officer if the applicant passes
these physical and mental tests
successfully there is little chance that
he'll be refused admittance later
[Music]
among other old record Webster's book on
pestilence use vivid descriptions of the
many ravages of japonic play
[Music]
this disease is constantly present in
the Orient and this fact makes it an
ever-present threat to the United States
and its possession the germ that causes
bubonic plague is carried by fleas that
live on rats and other rodents rats are
great travellers and vessels a dwarves
must use wrap guard to keep them from
coming aboard
notice how this rat balances himself
with his tail now he attempts to clear
the rat guard will he succeed it looks
like he'll make it
no he admit defeat and he returns to the
war yellow fever the fearful yellow Jack
which once struck terror to the south is
one of the best examples of a dread
disease now almost entirely wiped out by
science it is transmitted principally by
a particular kind of mosquito with the
mosquitoes which transmit the disease
exterminated yellow fever is eliminated
although yellow fever has been banished
from our shores since 1905 it still
exists in South America and Africa and
recent developments in air travel again
make it a menace to the United States to
combat this menace the yellow fever
mosquito must be eliminated from ships
and airplanes and infected persons must
be detected and isolated
although the mosquitoes which spread
yellow fever usually fly but a
relatively short distance they have been
carried by airplanes for thousands of
miles it's only by the exercise of the
utmost care and constant watchfulness
that this dangerous ever threatening
disease is kept outside our borders when
there arrives at a fort of entry an
airplane which might bring in the yellow
fever mosquito the passengers and crew
are inspected for symptoms of the
disease an important part of the
inspection is the taking of the
temperature for evidence of fever
the flame is gone over thoroughly with a
vacuum cleaner to recover any yellow
fever mosquitoes that might be aboard
then the cabin and all inflows faces in
the plane are sprayed with insecticide
that destroys these dangerous tests the
opening of air routes to the Orient has
created serious problems in preventing
the introduction of diseases
particularly cholera and smallpox into
Hawaii and the United States
[Music]
when the country was small travel was
slow and distances in travel time were
much greater than they are today then
there was less need for action on the
part of the federal government itself in
preventing the spread of epidemics but
with the increased rigidity of travel
the expansion in territory and the
concentration of population this work
became important with increase in
interstate traffic the need for uniform
quarantine regulations became apparent
and by the consent of the states and
under the Commerce Clause of the
Constitution Congress provided for
federal control of both interstate and
international quarantine the sanitary
control overall water supplies used for
drinking or keulen Airi purposes on
interstate carriers is one of the
activities of the Public Health Service
in connection with the prevention of the
interstate spread of disease it is
obvious that this is a tremendous task
the water included in these supplies
comes from almost 3,000 sources in this
work the cooperation of the state and
city health authorities is given to the
Public Health Service in taking supplies
of drinking and culinary water on board
vessels connections are made direct to
the supply of pipes and the possibility
of contamination of the water during
this process is thereby reduced to a
minimum here we see a supply of drinking
water being taken aboard a steamship at
one of our ports the same sanitary
precautions are carried out when
drinking water is taken aboard train
frequent inspections are made of this
procedure
the passenger can therefore feel a sense
of security when he quenches his thirst
from the water cooler or drinks water
with his meals in the dining car the
fight against bubonic plague is a fight
against the wrath he must be trapped
poison starved out built out everything
must be done to rout this animal the rat
has been called man's most destructive
and dangerous enemy he is certainly a
most dangerous test in the case of
bubonic plague he is sturdy furtive and
crafty and he readily matches his
cunning against out of his enemy the rat
catcher must know the habits of this
animal and it is only with such
knowledge combined with actual
experience that he can qualify as an
expert in what may indeed be called a
specialized field the rats are tagged
too sure the locality in which they are
caught and are then sent to the
laboratory for examination some of the
rats that are taken alive are put into
bags to preserve for identification and
examination any fleas that they may
harbor here we see a sample days catch
of rats
in one of our large cities
at the laboratory the rats are combed
for fleas and their fleas are collected
for study and for testing to determine
whether or not they are infected with
bubonic plague
in certain western states plague a
spread from rats ground squirrels and
the fight against these animals is being
constantly carried on there
[Music]
the following are typical scenes of the
regions in the east central sections of
this country in which trachoma is
chiefly found in these rural sections
life was somewhat primitive and the
sanitary conditions were conducive to
the spread of the disease because of the
habits and customs of the people they
did not know that trachoma was spread by
means of the hands and by towels and
handkerchiefs and other articles which
may carry the discharges from the eyes
simply described trachoma is a chronic
infectious disease of the lining
membrane of the eyelid if the lives are
turned back a number of small granular
bodies resembling sago grains will be
noticed the disease produces a roughened
condition of the inside of the lid which
irritates the front of the eyeball
causing an inflammation which often
leads to blindness for many years the
Public Health Service has conducted a
campaign against this ancient disease as
early as 1912 dr. John McMullen of the
Public Health Service was sent to
Kentucky to make a survey of the
situation there a dr. McMullen what was
found in Kentucky and what was done
there well more than 18,000 persons were
examined in 1912 and between seven and
eight percent were found after coma many
had already been blinded by the disease
many others remained in darkroom
shielding their eyes with our arm some
had not seen life for months while
medication had existed for years and
checking up some years later the changes
were remarkable instead of many sore
eyed people and the almost universal
practice of wearing colored glasses
observed during the first survey
scarcely colored glass was seen few
pieces of active Takuma from the
standpoint of humane and economic
considerations there is no way to
estimate what this trachoma work has
been worth much of the work was done in
mountain regions by roads even now are
not good
usually medical officers traveled by
horseback often they had to walk the
work has now been turned over to the
state
instead of painful and sightless eyes to
destroy the joys of youth we now have
the precious gift of sight the future
must be drear to one destined to live in
darkness fortunately this boy was
discovered in time instead of blindness
added to other infirmities of old age we
have the ability to assume an economic
role in family affairs numerous
outbreaks of typhoid fever have followed
the use of shellfish grown in
contaminated waters this was a danger
that could be combated by examination of
the waters where eye stirs were grown
and forbidding the interstate shipment
of oysters originating in areas the
sanitary conditions of which were not
approved by the Public Health Service
because oysters from beds in
contaminated waters will not be
certified and shucking plants and
tanneries are required to be conducted
under proper sanitary conditions the
consumer can now enjoy this seafood with
a greater sense of security than
formerly
[Music]
an act of Congress authorizes an annual
conference between the Surgeon General
and the state health officers to discuss
important health matters here the
Surgeon General opens a recent
conference this annual conference of
state and territorial health officers
will come to order I am delighted to
greet you here today one of the most
significant events in public health
which has occurred in our lifetime
transpired last month when President
Roosevelt signed the bill appropriating
funds to launch the health security
focus this bill and the one authorized
under it offer a great promise to the
people of this country for better health
it is your task and my task to see that
this promise becomes a realization it is
to discuss the detailed means by which
we may attain the objectives held forth
in the Social Security Act at this
conference will be concerned I welcome
your advice these conferences provide
opportunities for planning effective
methods of state and federal cooperation
in attacking health problems of mutual
concern for many years of Public Health
Service has cooperated with the state
health officers in an effort to develop
and improve state and local health work
when necessary experienced service
officers are assigned as shown here for
periods of time to aid state and local
health departments in their special
health problems funds made available by
Congress have been matched by state and
local agencies and used to develop local
health services under the Social
Security Act provision for this
cooperative aid to these health services
have been greatly extended
[Music]
the city health officer of a Western
city receives a telephone call he picks
up the receiver and finds that it's from
a local physician this physician has a
case the symptoms of which resemble
epidemic encephalitis but there are some
features which make this diagnosis
uncertain the city Health Officer
remarks that he is greatly concerned as
he has had several similar cases
reported in the past few days the city
health officer decides to notify the
state health officer he calls him by
telephone and outlines the local
situation the state health officer
immediately reports to the Surgeon
General and asked him for a
the city Health Officer called an
assistant and instructs him to consult
with the local physician he is
definitely alarmed a little later a
telegram is received from the Surgeon
General
after the Public Health Service officers
have conducted a preliminary
investigation they call a conference to
discuss the situation gentlemen this
epidemic is growing at least 50 new
cases are being reported daily we must
encourage close and harmonious
cooperation between ourselves as
representatives of the Public Health
Service and the city county and state
health authorities the local medical
schools have made available their
laboratories and other facilities what
will be our policy as regards
information for the general public the
City Health Department are notifying the
public frankly of the situation business
must proceed as usual there must be no
panic there is an unusual plague of
mosquitoes just now I wonder whether
there's any connection test that theory
as fairly as possible the mosquito tests
were conducted on prison inmates who
voluntarily submitted themselves as
laboratory animals after these
experiments were made another conference
was called to discuss the results dr.
Williams
what are your results so far the
mosquito apparently does not transmit
this particular disease however our
investigations must be continued in
other direction the epidemic despite all
the pens or has not been done in society
we will transfer our studies the
National Institute of Health in
Washington as a result of intensive
studies at the laboratory it was
concluded that the disease was due to a
virus and several important new facts
regarding it were reduced from these
investigations
in preventing diseases spread through
unclean milk a safe milk supply is
essential tuberculosis several undulant
fever typhoid beef and other diseases
are spread through contaminated milk the
Public Health Service field that clean
milk properly pasteurized is the only
safe dose to drink and it has conducted
studies to determine the efficiency of
pasteurization procedures these
precautions they sure a safe and clean
milk supply to the ultimate consumer
that is if ultimate sanitary precautions
are observed by the ultimate consumers
themselves another form of assistance to
and cooperation with the states is
specially in times of emergency the
disastrous floods which frequently occur
in the United States illustrate an
emergency that may arise suddenly during
these floods the states frequently
request the help of the sanitary
engineers of the Public Health Service
in providing emergency purification and
protection for town and city water
supplies in the affected areas these
requests for aid or met with some
response in many instances water
purification machines are quickly
dispatched to the affected areas and are
put into operation by the sanitary
engineers as the water is pumped into
the reservoirs or distributing systems
it is treated with chlorine to make it
safe for human consumption
[Music]
in the fight against disease from a
public health standpoint it is
fundamentally important to know when
where in what numbers and under what
conditions various diseases are
occurring the Public Health Service
records the important communicable
diseases on charts which show their
seasonal prevalence note on these charts
how closely the cases for different
years follow the same general seasonal
pattern each separate line across the
chart represents a year for the
particular disease the service maintains
an intelligence office regarding the
occurrence of epidemic diseases in the
United States and foreign countries and
report to receive weekly from all
American councils their wide
distribution is shown on the map
whenever there's an outbreak of a
quarantine Obul disease anywhere in the
world the American Council at that place
promptly cable's this information to
Washington information is also obtained
from many other sources from local
health officers and state health
officers who report regularly by
telegraph and on cards like the card
shown here reports are also received
from officers at the Public Health
Service stationed abroad health officers
of foreign governments and international
health organizations such as the
International Office of Public Health
the Health section of the League of
Nations and the pan-american sanitary
bureau the information so collected is
compiled and published and is used by
quarantine officers of the Public Health
Service by our own local state health
authorities and by other government
throughout the world
[Music]
dr. Ellis Rao director-general of the
pan-american Union addresses a recent
conference tetraman of the conference at
this your closing session I want to
express to you individually and
collectively the deep appreciation of
the pan-american Union or the privilege
of having had you with us during the
period of your deliberations it is no
exaggeration to say that the third Pan
American Conference of directors of
health marks a distinct step forward in
that struggle of the nations of this
continent to improve the conditions of
life to eliminate the causes of disease
and to augment the efficiency of the
masses of the people
I wish therefore to congratulate you at
the same time to assure you that in the
future as in the past you may count upon
the earnest and enthusiastic cooperation
of everyone associated with the
pan-american union dr. H s coming
director-general as if an American
sanitary bureau now speaks general as
director the pan-american sanitary
Bureau and president of conference /
Jonah thank you I want to join the dr. L
in expressing appreciation to you for
leaving your important administrative
functions and your respective
governments for sending you to this the
most successful sanitary conference we
have had it point of progress supported
by you and your country's practical
plans formulated is by far the most
successful conference
I wish you Godspeed back to your
respective home
[Music]
[Laughter]
[Music]
scientific studies dealing with the
diseases of man were made by the Public
Health Service as early as 1886 these
studies have gradually expanded until
today the research of the Public Health
Service on the cause method of spread
and means of prevention of disease is
among the most important work that is
performed a research laboratory for the
Public Health Service calls the hygienic
laboratory was established in 1901 in
1930 Congress changed its name to the
National Institute of Health at this
famous Institute in Washington DC
most of the investigative work of the
Public Health Service is conducted the
diseases and conditions studied by the
service include a long list heart
disease is public enemy number one it is
first on the list of the causes of death
more than 300,000 persons die each year
in the United States from this car
the electrocardiograph has aided greatly
in the study and diagnosis of heart
disease next in importance of the cause
of death is cancer this disease results
in the death of about 135,000 people in
the United States annually malaria is
still an important public health problem
in at least 16 states of the union this
mosquito born disease exacts a toll of
sickness of more than 2 million cases
annually this patient is having a
malarial chill the fight against malaria
is the fight against the malaria
mosquito the prevention of mosquito
breeding by seeing that no containers
are left lying around to catch and hold
water and thus provide breeding places
for mosquitoes and by eliminating all
refuse files in so far as possible
in certain regions effective mosquito
control has been accomplished by dusting
water areas with a poisonous mixture
this dusting is done from trucks by hand
dusting machines and by airplanes
according to the conditions met with
another effective method employed is the
killing of larvae or wiggle tails by the
oiling of stagnant waters other
preventive measures include ditching for
drainage and keeping mosquitoes out of
the home by screening the protection of
the health of the industrial worker has
become a matter to which much attention
has been given new manufacturing
processes are frequently introduced new
hazards to the health of workers the
control of occupational diseases comes
within the province of the physician and
the engineer in many industries dust has
been found to be a serious hazard to the
health of the employees and exhaustive
studies of the various types of dust in
industry have been made by the Public
Health Service dusts are collected at
the plants and atmospheric and other
data are recorded these dust samples are
then taken to the laboratory where
they're carefully examined to determine
the concentration the size distribution
and the chemical and other
characteristics of the particles this
young lady is seen making a dust count
from a sample that was taken at one of
the plants
the Public Health Service has conducted
Studies on the mottled enamel of teeth a
disfiguring condition caused by an
excessive amount of fluid in the
drinking water in certain areas of the
United States these studies have shown
that mottled enamel is more prevalent in
this country that had been realized the
Public Health Service conducts Studies
on stream pollution a subject of growing
importance without constantly increasing
and concentrating population new
problems have arisen not only from the
increase of human waste discharged into
streams but also from the increase and
changing types of industrial wastes from
a public health standpoint the venereal
diseases are one of the most important
problems confronting those whose duty it
is to conserve the health of our nation
special laboratories are devoted by the
Public Health Service to the study of
various phases of this subject
one day simultaneous surveys of all
sources of treatment have been conducted
by the Public Health Service in
representative areas of the United
States covering approximately 1/4 of the
entire population of the country
estimates derived from these surveys
indicate that more than a million and a
half new cases of the venereal diseases
seek treatment annually in this country
cooperative study is conducted by the
Public Health Service with five of the
leading venereal disease clinics in this
country indicate that syphilis is
largely curable to attain recovery
however treatment must be started during
the first year of the disease the Public
Health Service cooperates with state and
local health departments in the
development of campaigns directed
against the venereal diseases
from time immemorial the law of the sea
has required vessels to provide medical
attention for their seamen this was a
difficult matter for the owners of ships
in the early days of the Republic
therefore in order to encourage its
struggling merchant marine Congress
established the marine hospital service
in 1798 to relieve the ship's of this
burden the 1st Marine Hospital in Boston
which was the first General Hospital in
that city furnished hospital care for
sailors from some of the famous war
sloops and frigates of the war of 1812
today there are 25 modern thoroughly
equipped hospitals in this service
located within the United States these
hospitals have an aggregate bed capacity
of approximately 6,000 bed and give
treatment to about 300,000 persons
annually while almost as many more apply
each year for other service including
physical examination new marine
hospitals have recently been built at
Baltimore's Cleveland Detroit Galveston
Memphis New Orleans Norfolk San
Francisco and Seattle the Marine
Hospital of Stapleton New York which is
the one shown here has been enlarged to
make it a 1,000 bed institution these
hospitals are professionally staffed by
medical officers both competent and
humane secured by examination and
selection only qualified graduate nurses
professional dietitians and Skills
therapeutic aides are employed these
hospitals have all the specialized
services ie R nose and throat a
thoroughly equipped x-ray Department
dental department with the most modern
equipment hydrotherapy physiotherapy
venereal disease and some have a
psychiatric service they are provided
with the most modern appliances for the
diagnosis and treatment of disease
gentle treatment is furnished at all
marine hospitals by dental officers most
of the patients entering especially the
merchant seamen are suffering from
septic mouth conditions with the
elimination of dental infection many
remarkable recoveries have been reported
the facilities of the marine hospitals
were available without cost to American
seamen employed on board any registered
enrolled or licensed vessel of the
United States to officers and enlisted
men of the Coast Guard to officers and
crews of vessel to the lighthouse
service to certain keepers and assistant
keepers of the lighthouses to immigrants
detained at the immigration station to
semen from vessels belonging to the
United States Army to beneficiaries of
the United States employees Compensation
Commission to members of the Civilian
Conservation Corps in various sections
of the country to patients of the United
States Veterans Administration and to
person's afflicted with leprosy this is
the National left wrist area Matt
Carville Louisiana begins four licenses
pilot other officers of vessels the
United States registry and lighthouse
keepers must pass an examination
conducted by medical officers of the
Public Health Service these examinations
are for vision for color blindness and
for hearing the service must also pass
upon the physical ability of sailors
qualifying as able-bodied seamen
regulations require all ship's officers
to be versed in first aid
therefore the Public Health Service has
organized courses of instruction for
such candidates in a number of the
larger port
not only does the service furnish
medical age of the Coast Guard but it
also sends its medical officers with the
cruising cutters on the North Atlantic
ice patrol to furnish medical care to
the officers and crews of these vessels
the service also sends medical officers
with the Bering Sea seal patrol the
Coast Guard makes an annual cruise along
the coast of Alaska medical and dental
officers of the service are set on this
cruise
they give medical examinations and
treatment to the natives these include
dental treatment and extraction this is
the only medical service that is
available to many of these Native
Alaskans the National leprosarium
which is a Marine Hospital at Clerval
Louisiana has under treatment more than
300 patients who are Leppard the left
row cerium has an administration
building and the main hospital treatment
by the various methods and agents used
has yielded most encouraging results and
there have been many recoveries or
arrested cases during the last ten years
over a hundred and fifty patients have
been discharged to their homes no longer
a menace to the public health and the
leprosy arrested sports are provided by
baseball diamonds and tennis courts and
the younger patients greatly enjoy these
outdoor recreational activities the
cottages for the patients are
comfortable and are provided with ground
for gardens in which many of the
patients take much delight life for
these unfortunate persons is made as
comfortable and as pleasant as possible
in the attractive inner court to Leopard
children may be seen playing around the
pool medical aid to vessels without a
physician has been made possible by the
development of radio frequently men are
injured or suddenly develop an acute
illness on ships far out at sea if
there's no physician aboard the Public
Health Service is notified by radio many
lives are saved each year thanks to this
radio service or charter radio for
medical advice all right
the message from the vessel is received
by a commercial radio station which
immediately relays it by telephone to
the nearest Marine Hospital
[Music]
he'll respect medical advice scientist
mr. Estonia send this reply man
apparently has acute tonsillitis put him
to bed on liquids I have him drink cold
water freely use hot alkaline goggles
every two hours give 10 grains of
aspirin every three hours for four doses
reports progress in 12 hours
scientists US Marine Hospital a merchant
seaman may have been suddenly attacked
by illness on approaching port here
again the medical officers of the Marine
Hospital are notified by radio but in
this case an ambulance is sent from the
hospital to the dock to meet the boat
the patient is taken off the vessel on a
stretcher he is placed in the ambulance
and rushed to the Marine Hospital on
arriving at the hospital he has taken
directly to the ward for examination and
diagnosis the medical officers examined
him carefully and with the aid of the
history of the case that is furnished
them they make their diagnosis in this
instance it's definitely an acute attack
of appendicitis the patient must be
operated on at 1:00 he is therefore
taken to the operating room where the
Troublesome appendix is removed
[Music]
an act of Congress requires that the
medical care in federal penal and
correctional institutions be furnished
by the Public Health Service the
prisoners are given thorough physical
examinations eye ear nose and throat
chest dental and other examinations they
are also given various types of mental
tests these mental tests will afford
valuable data for the study of different
types and characteristics of prison
inmates which differentiate delinquents
from non delinquents when the United
States Public Health Service hospital
was established in Lexington Kentucky
the problem of narcotic drug addiction
was put under the banner of medicine
until that time this problem had been
regarded almost solely as a correctional
one the hospital consisting of a group
of buildings covers an area of
approximately 12 acres the buildings are
constructed in quadrangular form
providing a large central court serving
as an instance plaza to the various
departments and unit to the hospital
from here one gains access to these
units especially provided for the
reception and treatment of new
admissions for the treatment of those
suffering with intercurrent diseases and
for the intensive study of patients and
of those requiring special forms of
treatment this part of the institution
constitutes the professional center of
the hospital to meet the need for a
better treatment for drug addiction
special studies of patients are
necessary the hospital is fully equipped
and adequately staffed for this purpose
opportunities for outdoor work are
afforded to patients through the
operation of a thousand acre farm these
farm activities include the operation of
a modern dairy the raising of hogs and
poultry and intensive truck farming
indoor work for patients includes the
operation of a laundry a modern garment
shop for the manufacture of clothing
worn by the patient's not for sale and
other activities that are necessary for
the maintenance and operation of the
hospital supervised outdoor recreation
is desirable and necessary for the
health of the patient it promotes good
fellowship and normal human
relationships
the career officers of the Public Health
Service constitute a mobile sanitary
core whose members are available for
service whenever needed in the United
States or foreign country for epidemic
duty for quarantine duty or for
investigation work the Honor Roll
contains the names of many men and women
who contracted diseases in line of duty
and of many who have made the supreme
sacrifice these workers conducted their
investigations fearlessly with full
knowledge of the dangers that confronted
them they dedicated themselves to
humanity and made their sacrifice on the
altar of science other workers were not
less fearless but more fortunate not
less assiduous in their devotion to duty
but more favored on the field of battle
the Public Health Service conducted
relentless fight against disease
violently and steadily no martial music
to inspire no tumult or shouting to
sustain the battlefield is silent but
the grim fight the personal ding the
satisfaction of accomplishment are there
even though the fight is frequently
directed against an unseen and an
unknown enemy
[Music]
[Music]